tears of the kingdom is a game about
exploration like breath of the wild the
newest Zelda installment finds its
identity in the open world it presents
any sandbox of tools it gives you to
explore that world and Beyond just
journeying around the grounds of Hyrule
now we get to dive through its sky and
into its deepest depths the core
experience of the game that everything
else Builds on is the open exploration
of its World whether prompted by the
main quest lines or sidetracked by
shrines side quests and cork trials the
game plainly tells us to go and seek it
wants us to get lost in the lands of
Hyrule while finding answers solving
puzzles and building zonai machines that
more often than not don't work too well
this threat of Discovery runs to the
very DNA of the game and because of this
I think there is one action every player
should take or at least try during their
playthrough of Tears of the Kingdom turn
off your Hut now the game doesn't
actually let you fully turn off the HUD
but there is a setting to turn your HUD
to Pro mode this setting removes most of
the HUD most of the time and some of it
all of the time you can still see
important button prompts your stamina
bar when it depletes and your hearts
when you take damage but beyond that you
don't get to see much else no minimap or
sensors and no persistent objects in the
screen's Corners all of these elements
normally exist because they provide
useful information to the player but
they can also take the player away from
what's really important the game World
these are somewhat meta phenomena that
obviously don't exist fully in the game
World itself link probably doesn't keep
track of how he feels by the number of
Hearts he has left no the HUD elements
are largely constructs designed for the
player to tell the player how link is
feeling and to help with navigating the
world but because these are things
outside of the game World itself they
can distract and even take away from the
experience of playing the game and
exploring its world
in terms of the actual HUD elements
minimaps have already been a big point
of discussion in game analysis the open
world zeldos aren't as prone to minimap
dependency as some other open world
games but they still make it easy for a
player to find themselves constantly
glancing down to the minimap instead of
navigating the actual terrain of the
world it's attempting ever-present
crutch that is really easy to fall back
on and the other elements of the HUD
that don't need constant monitoring can
still cause issue too they can become so
ingrained that a player almost forgets
they're there but unfortunately their
impact doesn't evaporate in the same way
once you switch the HUD into Pro mode
and those elements disappear you realize
just how big of a difference they make
how much their absence changes the
feeling of walking around and exploring
in game the first time I switched over
the lack of Hud let the feeling of The
Game come through with a new sense of
Vitality it felt a lot more like freely
being in Hyrule just me as Link in the
open world no artificial gaming
interface disrupting the flow between
world and player
now I'm not here to say that it is
always and for every person objectively
better to play with Pro Hut after all
Nintendo could still do a better job
with the pro setting for example it
would be great to have an auto mode
where more elements show up in combat
when they're more necessary but High
during quieter exploration and beyond
that everyone is obviously going to have
different preferences and proclivities
that suit them and their playthroughs
differently there's no one way to play
that would give a better experience for
all players that said there are still
some relatively objective aspects of
playing a game that can lead to a better
or worse experience with the medium we
can see this in other media really
easily for example movies benefit from
theaters with quality speakers and
screens where moviegoers can focus on
the full audio visual spectacle of the
film books are generally best enjoyed in
a quiet relatively peaceful setting that
allows for deep concentration or focus
on the words and I think the same is
true for experiencing games while it may
manifest in different ways an engagement
or immersion into the game game is
important for a player to really mesh
with their player character and
experience the feelings the game wishes
to transmit I think playing with Pro HUD
will increase this immersion for most
people or it at least has the potential
to so I made this video to tell you to
give it a shot maybe you'll like it
maybe it will feel meh but then you try
playing the game for a while getting
familiar with it and then try Pro HUD
again you'll be more comfortable with
the game so the lack of information the
HUD provides won't be as much of a
detriment and you might notice a bigger
difference in taking something away that
has become a more core part of the lens
through which you see the game with it
gone the game might open up to you in an
originally unexpected way it might just
be a breath of fresh air and maybe you
try all that but you still don't care
for it maybe you actually just want to
always see your hearts or your
temperature or some other element and if
so fair to you obviously I can't dictate
the tastes of every player but I think
the experience of a clean screen
exploration of this new and improved
Hyrule is something pretty magical and
at the very least I think it's worth a
shot
as everyone explores and discovers this
new Behemoth of a game I'll be around
uploading videos on it generally more
lore on explanation than this one my
next might be explaining the ending or
talking about the secret Stones so make
sure you stick around if something like
that sounds interesting and for my Elden
ring viewers don't worry Elden ring
content isn't gone I'll be returning to
it soon enough so with that thanks for
watching peace